[Music]
first we are very grateful to our polish
allies for the invitation the generosity
and the support
as our paratroopers have come into this
country i think it shows the ironclad
alliance between both of our nations
the deployment of elements of the 82nd
airborne division are here to enhance
the readiness interoperability across
all domains
with our polish allies
and if necessary defend any portion of
nato
of course we do this uh annually in our
exercises most recently
in the last eight months we worked very
closely with the polish sixth airborne
brigade and conducted swift response
here in europe and
again this is a very
strong relationship that goes back many
years
our national contribution here in poland
shows our
solidarity with all of our allies here
in europe and obviously during this
period of uncertainty
um
we know that
we are stronger together
this deployment is a prudent measure
to ensure that collectively that with
prevention of any war aims it's
defensive in nature
and clearly this is about ensuring
uh the protection of all of the alliance
[Applause]
foreign
you